d'un coup d'oeil david évalue la qualité
du bois et indique d'un trait les
parties à éliminer trop
[Musique]
avec ses collègues il passe chaque jour
quatre kilomètres de bois sous leurs
machines automatisées
mais dans quelques semaines c'est un
tout autre défi qu'ils vont devoir
relever
découpez les futurs poutres de la
charpente de notre dame
une fierté pour tous les employés de la
scierie je pouvais raconter à mes
enfants et mes petits-enfants notre
pierre à l'édifice
c'est une fierté surtout que je dois
faire partir des plus jeune personne à
participer je pense il ya une certaine
pression mais surtout casser des bois
qui ont une grosse valeur la société cir
au bois vient d'être retenu comme sur
référent parmi une vingtaine d'autres en
france et l'entreprise dans n'est pas à
son coup d'essai en matière d'édifices
religieux
elle a déjà fourni du bois pour la
mosquée hassan ii au maroc ou le temple
des mille bouddhas la boulaye des
prestations que les ancêtres de la
famille n'aurait jamais imaginé
lorsqu'ils ont créé la syrie à la fin du
19e siècle
il ya cent ans l'activité de la société
cir au bois c'était se contenter de
servir la mine qui était très important
à l'époque
et puis de servir les boulangers qui
utilisaient du bois pour faire leur pain
parce que sur l'histoire de la maison
siro sur 125 ans d'existence
on peut bien consacrer quatre jours à la
reconstruction de cette notre dame qui
tout le monde à dos au fin fond de notre
coeur et qui motive tout le monde pour
notre dame 100 mètres cubes de chaînes
seront découpées et sécher pendant un an
à saint bérain sous sanvignes
les arbres sont actuellement prélevé un
peu partout en france et en bourgogne
dans lyonnais dans la nièvre